fourth lesson
she taught me was to believe in myself
she made me believe that i'm the most
special person in the world
and that i can achieve anything and then
she would tell me that since i was a
little baby
until i was a big baby and
her excitement about the little
successes in my life
really made me fall in love with the
successes of others
she inspired me to enjoy the success of
others
to believe in the people around me to
encourage them
to dream big to work hard to accomplish
anything
because she did that for me and you know
it's heartbreaking to think that
very few people in my life believed in
me
i was always a a dreamer i reached for
the stars
and most people even people who loved me
gave me what they thought was wise
advice
to stick to the safe path to to be
reasonable to
find stability comfort
all those kinds of things that seem wise
in the grand scheme of life
to be normal and she didn't
she told me to go big to dream big
and that i could accomplish anything i
want to do
everyone is different and i'm not a
parent
and i think that kind of over-the-top
encouragement can
perhaps spoil some people or give them a
false sense of ego
but for somebody like me who was
genetically
full of self-doubt and
forgive me for saying even disliking
myself
she was a breath of fresh air
and so whatever dream i have now that
still
stays with me is the
fire she kindled is the
fire she kept going and a fire that
will never die because of her
over the past several years there's been
many days that
i'm grinded to a halt with self-doubt
i feel that in all kinds of ways i'm a
fraud
for daring to dream to go outside of
what i'm supposed to do what other
people much smarter than me are telling
me i'm supposed to do
in those moments when i say
i listen to my heart i listen to my gut
i really listen
to the thing that my grandmother left me
it's it's that fire the belief in myself
that i can do anything that
that the dreams i have are not just
silly dreams
they're visions of a future that i can
create
if i work hard i can create
you